ja und die achse bonn berlin steht heute
quasi in einer standleitung liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer denn sie
sehen es mein kollege erhard scherfer
steht bereits bereit vor der
haushaltsdebatte im deutschen bundestag
beginn der haushaltswoche hat er gäste
da und deswegen gebe ich jetzt direkt ab
nach berlin zu erschaffen
danke claudia dem ist und wohin ja schon
mal von zauberei die rede war im
gespräch mit rainer holznagel hier ist
hat ein bisschen was von einem
zauberkasten hat auch der haushalt 23
finde ich jedenfalls um fast 5 445
milliarden euro also rund 50 milliarden
weniger als der aktuelle und trotzdem
will die koalition mehr fortschritt
wagen also möglichst viel von ihrem
koalitionsvertrag umsetzen wie durch
zauberei sollen bürgerinnen entlastet
werden investitionen zudem steigen und
bei all dem soll auch noch die
schuldenbremse eingehalten werden was
unter anderem durch einen schon
bekannten trick passiert indem man
nämlich eine sonder schuld in ein
sondervermögen deklariert und sie ein
bisschen außerhalb des eigentlichen
haushaltes platziert hat und wir fragen
uns aber trotzdem was passiert
eigentlich wenn das weiße kaninchen
namens wirtschaftswachstum nicht so aus
dem zylinderkopf hüpft wie erwartet und
vielleicht auch ein bisschen weniger
hoch ob das ganze dann insgesamt noch
aufgehen wird fragen wir mal nach bei
dennis rohde dem haushaltspolitischen
sprecher der spd-fraktion guten morgen
ihn und helge braun ist bei uns der
vorsitzende des haushaltsausschusses und
mitglied der cdu csu fraktion auch einen
schönen guten morgen herr rohde bevor
wir uns der frage magie oder solides
handwerk wittmann werfen wir noch einen
blick auf das entlastungspaket das am
wochenende beschlossen worden ist wie
und wo finden sich eigentlich diese 65
milliarden die vielzitierten die die
bürgerinnen entlasten sollen wieder in
diesem haushalt im neuen sicher in
verschiedenen haushalten wieder die
finden sich im bundeshaushalt wieder der
hat allein im jahr 2022 deutliche umsatz
steuer mehreinnahmen der findet sich in
den landeshaushalten wieder wir sind ja
zum beispiel bereit das neuen euro
ticket 15 milliarden euro zu finanzieren
das eigentlich eine hoheitliche aufgabe
der länder auch die haben mehrwertsteuer
mehreinnahmen
allein in den ersten sechs monaten
generiert die finden sich zum teil im
sondervermögen energie und klimafonds
wieder wenn wir die aussetzung der co2
und besitzt über zwei preises besprechen
und die werden in einem system des
strompreises selbst generiert wir wollen
ja eine umgekehrte eeg-umlage schaffen
um diesen effekt den wir gerade beim
strompreis haben das eigentlich
erneuerbarer günstiger sind aber teurer
verkauft werden um zu drehen also ein
ganz vielen verschiedenen positionen das
phänomen was ich meine und bekommen auch
gleich sofort zu ihm das phänomen dass
ich meine dieser entwurf der heute
eingebracht wird ist ja besteht ja schon
am wochende wer also ist auch älter als
der beschluss vom wochenende und
trotzdem verändert sich nichts im
haushalt also da hat sich ja das ist ja
nichts dazu gekommen
natürlich wird sich aus dem haushalt
verändern wir starten jetzt mit dem
parlamentarische verfahren und wir
wissen dass wir im herbst ja noch mal
auch eine neue steuer bekommen und auf
die dann natürlich auch noch einmal
reagieren und sie haben gerade gesagt
was passiert jetzt eigentlich wenn das
wirtschaftswachstum runtergeht und das
wirtschaftswachstum runter geht darf der
staat mehr schulden machen weil dann die
konjunktur komponente der schuldenbremse
schwächer ist also wir das an anderer
stelle wieder ausgeglichen ich glaube
das ist ein solides handwerk mit dem man
die 65 milliarden finanzieren habe ich
zu meiner koalition wahrscheinlich
nochmal spannend herr braun ist das
paket
zumindest in einigen punkten auf dem
richtigen weg oder ist die koalition da
auf dem völlig falschen pfad ihrer
meinung nach also grundsätzlich ist es
in dieser phase unerlässlich das
entlastungspaket gibt aber wir haben ja
jetzt auch schon einige beispiele
gesehen mit dem tank rabatt zum beispiel
oder dem neuen euro ticket das sind
dinge die haben uns sozusagen die
haushalte stark belastet sind aber schon
rum also jetzt wenn die eigentlichen
probleme auftreten wirken die gar nicht
mehr man muss einfach sagen wenn wir die
ursachen von inflation und energiepreis
shop nicht schnell bekämpfen sondern
versuchen mit immer neuen entlastungs
paketen zu finanzieren dann dreht sich
die preisspirale weiter und dann haben
bürger und der stadt relativ schnell
leeren taschen das fehlt ihrer meinung
nach ich glaube die angebotsseite also
energie einkaufen und energie
produzieren dass es ganz entscheidend
inflation ist eine zutiefst und soziales
ereignis weil sie alle stärker belastet
und diejenigen die am wenigsten geld in
der tasche haben können sich am
wenigsten wehren und eins muss man sagen
die dimension ist so groß dass wir mit
allen anstrengungen entlastungs paketen
ob sie wichtig sind oder nicht und das
spüren die bürger auch immer nur die
spitze des eisbergs bekämpfen können
viel trifft die bürger eben doch und
deshalb ist das thema des tages aus
meiner sicht diese frage produzieren wir
mehr energie stichwort neue brennstäbe
zum beispiel auch für kernkraftwerke das
löst das problem an der ursache wenn wir
zu halten das jahr 2023 mit einem
ungelösten energieproblem bei weiter
hoher inflation gegen glaube ich auch
sind die eckwerte dieses haushalts sehr
in gefahr helge braun hat unter anderem
einen inflationsausgleich angesprochen
da wollen sich ja unter anderem jetzt
die sogenannten zufall dass gewinne
abschöpfen und damit auch den
bürgerinnen helfen und den bürgern haben
sie irgendeine konkrete idee stammt von
der umsetzung wie das gelingen kann und
was da überhaupt zusammen kommt an geld
was dann sinnvoll eingesetzt werden kann
das besondere ist ja dass das nicht über
den bundeshaushalt geschieht sondern ist
geschieht ja im system der
stromerzeugung an sich wären wir
momentan einen effekt dass der
strompreis festgelegt wird nach dem
teuersten einkaufspreis dass das gas das
heißt unternehmen die im großen zb
erneuerbare einkaufen machen gerade
milliardengewinne und wir wollen jetzt
die eeg-umlage die er so ausgestaltet
war dass man damals gesagt etwas kosten
erneuerbare mehr und das geht in der
rückvergütung quasi umdrehen und sagen
was sind erneuerbare günstiger und das
geht in der rückvergütung im system
selbst das wird nicht über den
bundeshaushalt fließen deshalb ist es
auch nicht für den bundeshaushalt zu
beziehen sonst ein system in sich ich
gehe aber davon aus dass zweistellige
milliardensummen zu zustande kommen
werden das sind so die berechnung die
ich kenne wie sie da ähnlich
optimistisch also das muss vor allen
dingen diese korrekturen am strommarkt
design müssen schnell erfolgen weil wir
ja die preisspitzen aktuell schon sehen
und das ist eine sehr komplizierte
operation dass er mir auch wichtig dass
wir gerade bei den entlastungsmaßnahmen
und so jetzt auch transparent im
haushalt abbilden was bedeutet das
eigentlich also als vorsitzender des
haushaltsausschusses dieses sozusagen
diese aussage zauberer finanzminister
irgendwo finden wir immer noch geld das
macht mir große sorgen weil am ende auch
versteckte schulden müssen von irgendwem
am ende zurückbezahlt der fdp-haushälter
fricke rechnet mit habe ich gelesen im
härtesten und umfangreichsten
haushaltsberatungen seit 2002 muss sie
erst mal nachgucken das war der erste
haushalt den euro 2002 womit rechnen sie
als vorsitzender des
haushaltsausschusses
also ich glaube auch dass wir wollen ja
den haushalt im november abschließen und
sind wir mutmaßlich mitten sozusagen im
zentrum der aktuellen krise und deshalb
glaube ich auch dass gerade in den
letzten tagen da noch sehr viel
verantwortung auf dem haushaltsausschuss
landet aber dafür sind wir auch da die
regierung machten entwurf schlägt was
vor und haben die verantwortung zu
beschließen was dann wirklich gemacht
wird im vorfeld gab es kritik an dem
haushaltsplan für das nächste jahr unter
anderem vom bundesrechnungshof aus dem
entwurf werde die wahre lage der
bundesfinanzen nicht deutlich hieß es da
der haushaltsausschuss kennt dem bericht
natürlich wie ehrlich ist dieser entwurf
den sie daher heute wurde der heute ins
parlament geht ich glaube dass jedem
haushälter jeder haushälterin die wahre
lage des kunsthaus bekannt ist und auch
das was der bundesrechnungshof
kritisiert dass er sagt da gibt es ein
sondervermögen was bedient wird dagegen
den kernhaushalt das ist ja alles über
das alles transparent das kann man
nachlesen natürlich ist es so dass
aufgaben aus dem kernhaushalt zum
beispiel in energie- und klimafonds
ausgelagert wurden aber das machen wir
seit vielen jahren so ich finde nicht
dass das getrickst ist aber eigentlich
ist es ja trotzdem beschummelt weil die
zusätzlichen schulden sind ja da auch
wenn sie jetzt nicht in dem eigentlichen
haushaltsplan stehen die schulden des
energie und klimafonds sind im letzten
jahr auf genau die sondervermögen
bundeswehr beispielsweise und auch die
stunde sondervermögens bundeswehr sind
ja
verfassungsrechtlich von der
schuldenbremse ausgenommen worden sie
bekommen irgendwann einen eigenen
tilgungsplan das hat das parlament auch
mit den stimmen der union so beschlossen
ich weiß nicht was daran intransparent
sein soll es ist ein gesetzesbeschluss
eine grundgesetzänderung gewesen das
kann man im grundgesetz nachlesen also
ich finde die kritik des
bundesrechnungshofes an dieser stelle
etwas überzogen herr braun ich finde die
kritik sehr gerechtfertigt weil man ja
sagen muss es ist nicht nur das
sondervermögen bundeswehr was wir mit
einer grundgesetzänderung sehr klar
aufgestellt sondern ein
nachtragshaushalt einen ergänzungs
haushalt und weitere sondervermögen das
ist in der summe so intransparent ich
würde mir wünschen dass wir das was
wirklich die bürgerinnen und bürger
zurückzahlen müssen auch wieder stärker
einfach im bundeshaushalt abbilden dass
man darunter die zahl sid was sind
unsere neuen schulden das wäre glaube
ich sehr sehr sinnvoll können sie sofort
sagen können sie auch direkt reagieren
was ich noch hinzufügen wollte ist es
wird ja eigentlich die schuldenbremse
wenn man es mal richtig zusammen rechnet
wird ja eigentlich nicht wirklich
eingehalten bei allen argumenten die sie
eben angeführt haben erstmal suggeriert
helge braun ja gerade es gebe mehrere
haushalte das stimmt natürlich nicht das
weiß auch der nachtragshaushalt
verändert den haushalt der ergänzungs
haushalt verändert den haushaltsentwurf
am ende gibt es einen haushalt es gibt
nicht einen ergänzungs haushalt ein
nachtragshaushalt ein haushalt sondern
einen transparenten haushalt in dem man
alles nachlesen kann indem das
zusammengefasst ist und das ist
transparent aber eigentlich ist die
nettokreditaufnahme nicht 17 milliarden
sondern 78 milliarden errichte lesen die
nettokreditaufnahme gegen die
schuldenbremse eingerechnet wird sind 17
2 milliarden da gibt es rechnungen wie
mit sondervermögen transferleistung wie
zum beispiel zuschüsse an die bahn zu
berechnen sind aber das war auch zu
zeiten wo die union regiert hat so da
hat sich nichts daran geändert aber
getrickst es bisschen trick ist doch
toll wenn man viermal so viele schulden
letzten endes als bürger zurückzahlen
muss gegenüber dem was man offiziell in
die schuldenbremse reihen rechnen sonst
natürlich sich fragen was es dann die
schuldenbremse noch wert und deshalb
müssen wir glaube ich dazu zurückkommen
zu dem grundgedanken der grundgedanke
ist wir wollen die bürgerinnen und
bürger der zukunft die junge generation
die auf krisen durchstehen werden muss
nicht zusätzlich belasten und deshalb
glaube ich es liegt die grundfrage nicht
was rechnen wir rein und raus sondern
wie hoch ist die belastung der
bevölkerung der zukunft herr schäfer es
tut mir leid aber auch das ist fachlich
nicht richtig war getilgt werden muss
nur das was über die schuldenbremse
hinaus geht das wird jedes jahr
ausgewiesen die normale
nettokreditaufnahme ist nicht unter der
tilgungs verpflichtung des bundes der
bund hat historisch sowieso nur zweimal
schulden getilgt während der großen
koalition
ansonsten hat er prolongiert also wenn
man jetzt sagt die bürgerinnen bürger
müssen wissen was alles in nächster zeit
widmen muss dann geht das nur über das
was über die schulter hinausgeht und das
weisen wir in einen eigenen beschluss
mit kanzler mehrheit im deutschen
bundestag aus also transparenter gibt es
auch an der stelle nicht also ich glaube
die zahl die der rechnungshof hier
erarbeitet hat war ja insofern wie
konnte man im haushalt nicht nachlesen
sondern dazu muss man sozusagen auf
blättern was wir an verschiedenen
beschlüssen der ampel in alleine in
dieser kurzen regierungszeit hatten und
deshalb glaube ich haushalts transparenz
eine rückbesinnung auf den kernhaushalt
als das zentrale instrument würde ich
mir sehr wünschen es gibt eine menge
unwägbarkeiten in diesen zeiten die
frage ist sind die zinsausgaben
hinreichend kalkuliert wir wissen nicht
wissen der ukraine krieg weitergeht wir
wissen nicht wie es mit den energie
kosten weitergeht mit der und allem was
dazugehört welcher welcher bereich macht
ihnen als haushälter im moment die
meisten sorgen sicherlich die im plan
bezogen auf den haushalt sicherlich zum
einen die inflation was die
ausgabenseite des bundes an geht aber
natürlich macht mir am meisten sorgen
die energiekosten die die bürgerinnen
und bürger zu stemmen haben und die sind
natürlich auch sehr haushalts relevant
weil wenn wir an eine situation kommen
dass die weiter davon laufen dann werden
wir ja auch über weitere entlastungen
diskutieren müssen am ende musste
erzählen dass wir die bürgerinnen und
bürger nicht alleine lassen und das wird
auch diese haushaltsverhandlungen
pflegen was wären ihre mittel auch aus
unionsfraktions sicht ja also ich glaube
das wichtigste das habe ich vorhin
angedeutet ist dass wir diese energie
krise beseitigen dass die inflation
aufhört inflation ist so etwas und
soziales und die dimensionen dieses
problems so groß dass wir mit
entlastungspaket dagegen nicht ankommen
und im bundeshaushalt müssen wir
natürlich auch auf diejenigen achten die
sich gegen diese preisspirale gar nicht
wehren können das sind zum beispiel
unsere krankenhäuser die an einer
öffentlichen finanzierung über die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung hängen
das ist zum beispiel die deutsche
wissenschaft unsere hochschulen die auch
alle die kostensteigerungen haben die
aber nicht von sich aus irgendwie die
preise erhöhen können sondern die einer
staatlichen finanzierung unterlegen und
die natürlich jetzt auch alle fragen
kriegen wir diese mehrkosten erstattet
weil im bundeshaushalt der so auf kante
genäht ist
dennis rother vielen dank dass ich heute
morgen bei uns gewesen sind helge braun
vielen dank auch ihnen in 12 minuten
fängt die haushaltswoche dann auch
richtig an ihm plenum heute etwas
verspätet wegen der sonderveranstaltung
wegen des staatsbesuchs des israelischen
staatspräsidenten vielen dank dass sie
hier gewesen sind wir freuen uns auf
spannende button wir werden sie auch
überwiegend live übertragen und dann den
einen oder anderen von ihnen ihr
wahrscheinlich auch noch mal sehen live
im pokal danke ihnen sie dürfen jetzt
rein gehen